notre ami doc gynéco va nous faire le
résumé de tout ce qui l'a retenu dans
cette émission il à knoxville et pain
c'est bien sûr le résumé de doc est ce
qu'on à dingle et chérie et bernois du
que ces partis ont déjà le think a
dépassé alors on a kravitz et macron et
le fait que le président s'intéresse à
la musique et aux artistes apprécient
dans l'idée sur la photo on la passe et
lenny kravitz justement ben alla et
macro une affaire qui prend trop
d'ampleur atteint des sphères trop élevé
en le punissant macron ce puni lui-même
charb le dessin censurer les religions
font attention à leur renommée n'a pas
parlé à leur image mais en fait parce
que je peux parler de trucs dont on a
parlé ce mois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir oui comment faire comprendre aux
aux hommes aux femmes aux enfants dans
un langage simple des questions
importantes d'actualité btp des
chroniqueurs vous y êtes arrivé alors
merci merci à vous le 22 septembre 2018
un jour important dans l'histoire d'anna
heureux d'être là
[Applaudissements]